hi there welcome at last it's getting
busy again for the shop owners on this
city block of Washington DC Amanda
mcclemons says more customers are
wandering into her home goods Boutique
during this week of reassuring economic
news when you see that headline interest
rates aren't going up or you see the
headline job numbers look great but you
know and inflation is slowing all of
those things I think help give people
confidence that we're going to be okay
and you know we're not headed into some
recession or you know global economic
meltdown and that can mean more money
spent on luxury items like the scented
candles and kitchen trinkets sold here
when people feel good they spend more
and that's great for small businesses
it's a welcome relief after the
pandemic's uncertainty which killed
nearly a third of U.S small businesses
at the crisis worst moment inflation
which peaked at nine percent a year ago
is now down by more than half half the
federal reserve's decision to keep the
Benchmark interest rate unchanged at
five to five and a quarter percent is a
reflection of the central bank's belief
that the U.S economy is indeed cooling
as intended by the previous 10
consecutive interest hikes
in light of how far we've come in
tightening policy the uncertain lags
with which monetary policy affects the
economy
and potential headwinds from credit
tightening
today we decided to leave our policy
interest rate unchanged
the Central Bank says the pause on
interest hikes is most likely temporary
at least one more increase is expected
this year that's to beat inflation back
down to pre-pandemic levels meanwhile
the U.S economy is expected to continue
a subdued growth
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington